today's topic a man repeats what a woman
says and gets banned from every Network
possible if you guys aren't aware levar
Dubois was on ESPN recently levar ball
father of Lonzo who was drafted second
overall by the Los Angeles Lakers is
known for making loud comments and being
funny on television as well as being the
entrepreneur on the CEO of big parlor
brand he was on ESPN's first take ahead
go ahead before I get back to him
levar can I switch gears with you for
cuz I have a question yes where's dears
with me anytime because I I know levar I
don't know him personally but I've seen
him in a lot of interviews so I know I
know what to expect your tweet it with
him it's a character I'm familiar with
hey man Michael Jordan to light in the
tail okay you know what
Big Dawg yes I light in the tail if you
want some of this let's go
[Applause]
before it's only two dudes better than
me and I'm both hey you know what la
stands for right what lavars awesome you
gotta tie them shoes down once you open
a day fly so numb what it's unbelievable
I said emphasis on the ball emphasis on
what on the ball I'm on the ball Eva
ball yes okay can I just give you a
little advice
twice David House can I just give you a
twice can I just give you a little
advice twice why but why but gonna act
like that sometimes
no but Sona I like that sir yes yes but
you know what like that is who he is as
a human being that is how he replies his
stuff for you to atribute some other
kind of meaning to it when it's just who
he is and how he express himself is very
new and the reason why is because no
[Applause]
metal gear solid alert sound bruh
when he invites you to come to his place
for strawberry pancakes and all you guys
do is laugh you guys are acclimated to
the weird kind of comments he's made so
yes this one I'd be like home but then I
was in a problem it was not even what he
said that was sexual
it's how the person took you that's what
it is that's a reality of it true cuz
imma invite you over for some pancakes
he would have said that too lady the
lady would have felt uncomfortable
saying it would have been sexual you can
take anything he says you could be
offended about it that's unbelievable
emphasis on the ball on the what can we
focus here I'm gonna bring you home for
some pancakes you're gonna do what to
who can we focus here I'm better than
Michael Jordan
yeah excuse me can we focus here like
you could say anything he says and bring
sensual front of cameras in front of
people in front of cameras this happy
yeah and you don't believe us when we're
scared about false claims I'm gonna
invite you to the house and make you
some pancakes for small bears uncle say
mr. cook I've never seen a model you
know this was a funny interaction
between Stevie Naismith and the fart
ball right strawberry ice on your place
oh I want that no time to destroy
Arizona I'll be there for that right
that's a funny interaction when you put
a female right there and all of a sudden
it's turned sexual and awkward and so
can you understand why some men are
reluctant to be comfortable around women
in the workplace so knowing that and
looking at the consequences of it why
would men want to put themselves in a
precarious position to talk to the
ladies in those positions at that time
if they know that that can be the
consequence and that's what we mean when
we say hey there's a space where men are
afraid of losing out on potential income
and opportunities just for being
themselves around women without even
doing anything weird this is a perfect
example of that so I just want people to
be more cognizant at that I tell this to
guys all the time when you are with
women in the workplace you keep it
strictly professional no jokes no
laughter no inside stuff no one-on-ones
where no one else can hear everything
because it's just not worth the risk but
anyways that's all we really want to
just cover you and let you guys know
where thoughts are on this topic so we
want your comments below do you guys
feel hesitant to work with women in the
workplace is a little bit weird for you
guys I guess so share your stories
believe in it and I said oops
stay in your lane
[Music]